welcome to the realm of Cutting Edge
technology have you ever wondered what
it would like to harness the immense
power of Google's Computing
infrastructure right at your fingertips
look no further for in digital brand
that there exist a phenomenon known as
Google collab an interesting Fusion of
cloud computing and collaborative
progress imagine a world where you can
effortlessly explore the Limitless
possibilities of artificial intelligence
machine learning and data analysis
without the need for expensive Hardware
or complex setups Google collab emerges
as Celestial Sanctuary offering you a
virtual laboratory to experiment create
and collaborate with like-minded
enthusiasts from every corner of the
globe in this exciting video we will
understand what is Google collab and
then we will have a complete overview of
it so let's start with the first topic
what is Google collab
so Google collab is a free online tool
that lets you do coding and data related
work on the internet
it's like having a virtual notebook
where you can write and run python code
without needing to install anything on
your computer with collab you can also
get data from different places and share
your work with others easily another
cool thing is that it gives you access
to powerful processors like gpus and
gpus which make tasks like machine
learning and data science faster and
more efficient so it's a great tool for
Learning and working on coding and data
projects
all right now let's have a look at
Google collab let's have a complete
overview of it
so first of all Google collab requires a
Google account for access to begin visit
the link
welcome to collaboratory
right welcome
to collaboratory as you can see
we click on this
then we'll click on this open this one
and sign in using our Google account or
credentials if you have already have a
Google account then you can just sign in
with that
all right
now let's start with the Google app
we'll simply write
lab
click on this
all right so this is the window that
appears when you click on that
first of all here we have is
example tab so the example tab offers
some initial examples to help you begin
using collab
for a comprehensive understanding of
collability features and efficient usage
of collab documents refer to the
document title overview collaboratory
features
it covers the fundamental aspects to get
you started efficiently
then there is recent tab all right so
the recent app displays a collection of
all the latest documents you have been
working on
all right now next is our Google Drive
tab the Google Drive tab features allows
you to import any of your previous
notebooks directly from your Google
Drive all right
then next is GitHub tab
so with the GitHub tab you have the
option to import notebooks from your own
GitHub repository or any public
Repository
simply provide the GitHub URL and you
can easily import notebooks from the
desired public repository then we have
is upload tab
so the upload feature allows you to
bring and work on your own Jupiter
notebooks that you have created on your
computer you can easily upload any file
from your local Machine by selecting the
choose file option
here it is choose file option now next
is our creating a notebook as you can
see here's a new notebook option and
there's a canceler option so creating a
notebook so to create a new notebook you
have the option to use the new notebook
button located at the bottom
by clicking on this button a new
Untitled notebook will be generated to
give it a specific name and simply click
on the current Type and Title name if we
want to name it
so as we have clicked on it yeah to give
it a specific name as we just said
simply click on the current Type and
Title name on The Notebook and make the
desired changes so let's say we want to
make it
sp1
let's just say the name
all right
so next is our cell
here we can see this is a cell
in a notebook cell server is the
fundamental building blocks encompassing
everything within
there are two types of cells actually
one is code cell as you can see
it contains executable code and has a
run button on the left side to execute
its content
this one
all right the output is displayed its
output is displayed below the code cell
after running
right then the next one is other one is
text cell so a text cell can include
text images links and more you can edit
its content by double clicking it the
textile supports markdown markup
language but you can also use the
provided options on top on the top for
formatting the right half of the cell
shows you how your edit text will appear
all right now the next point would be
adding a new cell like how to add a new
cell to add a new code or text cell use
the respective option at the top of the
work area as you can see these code or
text by clicking on this we can add code
cell and
texture
so clicking on any of these button
creates a new cell right below the
current one you can like let's say we
want to add this so now we want to add
this we can add this also
now you can rearrange the sell order
using the arrow options located at the
top right corner of each cell as you can
see
my using leads we can do that
yeah the up Arrow moves the cell one
position up while the down arrow moves
it down by one position
as we can see now adding and running a
code let's talk about this so by default
Google collab provides One initial code
cell which can be supplemented with
additional cells as desired these cells
serve as a platform for writing and
executing python code for instance let's
consider the following code
the trouble I have to let us delete all
these
yeah
so first of all we'll try one code let's
see how it goes
we'll simply write the code print
yeah print
my favorite color
is yellow
all right so now let's try to execute it
we can run it by clicking on this
running executing
so as you can see my favorite color is
yellow is being printed
so you can either press on this play
button to run the code or you can press
control plus enter to run the code as
you can see Control Plus enter to run
the cell
now next is changing the order of the
cell
so in Google collab you have multiple
options for rearranging cells you can
utilize the upsell and down sell buttons
located in the toolbar above the
notebook as we discussed previously
alternatively you can employ keyboard
shortcuts such as Ctrl shift F or Ctrl
shift down to move the chosen cell up or
down Additionally you have the
flexibility to reorder cells by clicking
on the cell number in the left Gutter
and dragging it to a different position
all right now deleting the current tab
so to delete the current tab in Google
collab you can use the delete icon
available over the top of the cell this
icon looks like a trash can and it will
remove the selected cell from The
Notebook as we can see this is the trash
can and this is just at the right upper
corner of the cell by clicking on this
we can delete the tab alternately you
can also use the keyboard shortcut
Ctrl m and d to delete the current cell
you can also right click on the cell and
select delete cells from the context
menu as you can see delete cell all
right
now we will understand how to add data
sets
so to add data sets from your local
device go to the left corner and click
on the folder icon as we can see this is
the left corner and this is the folder
icon
you click on that now click on the
upload icon and upload the desired file
this is the upload icon we click on that
now we can upload the desired file
whichever we want
all right you can also upload files by
writing a particular command let's try
writing that command okay
so we'll write from
Google
collab
all right after that we'll write
upload
equals
files Dot
upload
after that we'll put on brackets
right now we'll press Ctrl and enter
and here we can see choose files now
from here you can choose files so both
the ways you can upload files I'm just
telling
now let's understand how to like import
libraries in Google collab
so first of all you have to cancel
account we'll click on this
all right
so to import it we'll write
input
all right after that
we'll write
PD dot read
so here we are importing the CSV files
actually so we have to write like xpd
dot read underscore CSV
and inside this we'll write a
file let's say we have to check whatever
files like this is the sample data files
right
so you have to write the file name
actually which you want to import that
CSV file name I'm writing sample
underscore data all right
underscore yes the location you have to
put
dot CSV
position
all right so if you want to display 10
rows we'll write
e f Dot head
right 10. we will press Ctrl and enter
and we can see 10 rows are being
displayed
so this is how you can import and like
showcase the data and all
so this was about the Google collab we
have covered major things in that many
important things in that there are there
must be many more things in that that
you will explore when you will start
using it
so after understanding about Google
collab and hearing about various Cloud
Technologies if you want to become a
cloud engineer then check our post
Gadget program in cloud computing a
comprehensive course covers Microsoft
Azure AWS and gcp empowering you to
deploy Dynamic and independable
applications seamlessly discover the
intricities of these leading Cloud
platforms and master the core skill sets
needed for success join us to transform
your career and step confidently into
the world of cloud computing and roll
now and embark on an exciting Journey
towards a bright future in the crowd
industry don't miss this opportunity
all right with that we have come to the
end of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign